[Applause]
so many women are dealing with
life after divorce i know because i am
one of them
adjusting to a new life it is not easy
it takes almost years to figure out how
to navigate it
and it's a taboo subject and here
on this show we want to be gentle and we
want to figure things out
and we want to support each other and
learn from each other's life experiences
and wisdom and with that i want to
introduce luanna
who is currently dealing with divorce um
please take a look hi drew this is
luanna
um i'm going through a really tough
divorce situation right now and i know
you've been through the same thing
i've been married for 11 years separated
for three years i have three
beautiful children i think everything's
just
in limbo right now i mean the pandemic
has put a hold on
every single thing that needs to be done
i'm just i'm a single mom and
i'm just trying to stay positive i'm
taking it one day
at a time counting my blessings each and
every day
but i know that you can help me so could
we please talk about this
luana i would be honored to talk about
it
hi how are you hello hello good morning
thank you for having me
i'm gonna just start right out of the
gate and say that your
smiling eyes and your tone
tone is a big thing with me and it's uh
synonymous with energy
and your energy is clearly seeking the
light here
and wherever it took you to get to where
you
are you are in a place where you are
projecting
and radiating strength and light so i
commend you for the immense amount of
work it must have taken you
to get where you are right now it has
been a journey but i'm happy that i'm
here now i always told myself that
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel and i just have to
feel to heal so i was open to feeling
any pain
any happiness any ups and downs any joy
whatever
i felt that day i made sure to feel it
at 100
just so i know that i went through the
journey to get me to where i am right
now
how long were you married may i ask i
was married for 11 years and kind of
still right
because you know the the divorce is
still pending
i'm in limbo and so i am still married
but i was together with my ex for about
11 years
and how long has it been since you've
been separated
about three about three maybe going into
four
because my youngest daughter is four
years old so um
yeah since then and where divorce papers
aside
where do you feel like you're at in the
journey do you still feel like
everything
is as raw and fresh as if it was
yesterday or do you feel like the ship
is leaving the dock a little bit
the ship has almost left the dock i
can't say that i'm a hundred percent
there
but i certainly do not feel the same way
as i did
a few years back so time does heal
and i'm happy that i'm here now i'm so
glad to hear you say that because
everybody said that to me time
i think the way you described it was
really good and it
it i think what nobody talks about is
that it's going to take
probably a lot more time than you really
want it to or anticipate
yes it does take a little bit longer
because we
are as mothers we have that connection
with their fathers so
we can't really say it's out of sight
out of mind we still have that
connection we still have to interact
with them
so it does take a little bit longer and
but
you know as long as it you'll get to
where you need to go
then it should be fine i think it takes
such
a intricately woven
art to navigate divorce with children
and how we talk to those children and
how
we work with our exes in front of them
or to them how are you dealing with that
part
it was difficult in the beginning
because my emotions and my feelings were
so strong
but i had to keep thinking to myself
especially from
advice from family and friends that keep
your children
the number one priority what is best for
them and that's what you should
do not to say that you have to forget
about
your feelings but just keep them number
one
make sure what they see is positivity
and that no matter what the differences
are
and we do have differences you know
co-parenting difficulties
that we have disagreements about
a lot of things for example education
you know i
i'm a big believer in sending my kids to
catholic school where
he isn't so there's one disagreement but
we have to act as adults and he and i
have to be very mature and just
kind of do that on the side and it's
almost like putting up a show and my
kids are probably too young to even
understand what i'm saying right now but
you're kind of putting
putting a front you know in front of
them just to
make sure that they're seeing the
positive vibes going on
i know that this is so hard but i think
you're
at an amazing place a really
inspirational place
that i'm sure took years and really hard
work to get to
yes that i could definitely agree to and
i
take a lot of my strength from the women
who i know
are with me on this because i know there
are women out there who
feel the same way as i do and i know
that i have a team backing me up
just like you i know you're behind me
and i'm behind you all the way and we
support each other so i take a lot of my
strength
from the other women around me and that
and the other women who i know are going
through the same thing
[Music]
you